the prime minister's uh visiting uh
eastern europe uh next week do you think
that the government's doing enough
to protect the ukraine from the
depredations of mr putin
well i think the prime minister is right
to go and visit the region
we've criticized him for not going and
i'm not going to criticize him now for
going this is an incredibly
difficult volatile and serious situation
i think the defense secretary is
absolutely right to offer support and
support around intelligence support
around defensive
capability i'd if i had one disagreement
with the government listening to liz
trust there
it was that it was quite extraordinary
that she on the one hand was emphasizing
the importance of widening the sanctions
regime something we've called for for a
long time and working in concert with
our allies in order to implement that it
has far more effect on russia and on
president putin if we stand together in
the face of russian aggression but just
minutes later she was talking up a row
with the eu that the government has been
trying to keep going for the last few
years it seems to me these two things
are completely contradictory and most of
all not in britain's interests they're
certainly not in the interest of the
people of northern ireland but you can
see now why this is not in britain's
interests as a whole the the issues
around the protocol
could be dealt with with some creativity
and good will and i think the government
really ought to reassess the way that
it's handled that in the light of this
very serious situation that's developing
on the border of ukraine
so
but broadly speaking you you support
what they're doing um would there be
things that you
would do in addition
yes we've long called on the government
to widen the scope of the magnitsky
sanctions these are sanctions that apply
to individuals
and when the government introduces trust
forgive me it sounds from what liz trust
said that that's actually what they're
about to do would you will you be
supporting legislation if that's what
the effect of them that legislation is
if they do we've campaigned for it for
several years we pushed the government
to do it originally and i think my
understanding was that that was blocked
by the treasury if the treasury has
finally realized that that was a mistake
of course we'll support that and i think
the important message
from britain has to be that we stand
united in the face of russian aggression
with nato and with our allies we will
not allow this to stand and all
political parties should be working to
that end
there is a tricky um
uh issue to solve here there are worries
that the kremlin might put the squeeze
on by restricting
gas export to europe and that a third of
uh
europe's gas comes from from russia
market prices are already incredibly
high they're going to go up again
we're going to face our own problems um
do you think the uk can actually afford
to do what is necessary for example liz
trust more or less said
if there's an invasion that we should uh
put uh put a stop to nordstrom too do
you think we can
afford to do that
well i think there's two things the
first is that we've got to work very
closely with countries like germany that
are heavily much more heavily reliant on
on imports of gas from places like
russia to make sure that we're all
working together around this and i agree
with liz trust that
economic expediency cannot come before
security and the defense of the united
kingdom and the defense of democracy but
you know for over a decade now we've had
this
very very confused energy policy that's
been pursued by the government we've
lost a lot of our gas storage capability
that was given away
several years ago we haven't invested
sufficiently in
in renewables particularly around solo
the government took the axe to solar a
few years ago and removed the subsidies
that were that cut off at the knees an
industry that was really thriving and
developing grubs jobs growing at six
times the rate of the wider economy i
think we're now starting to see the
folly of that approach being played out
um at the border of ukraine
and that's one of the reasons why we've
been saying for some time now that not
only would investment in renewables and
in the energy industry and in helping
energy intensive industries to adapt do
a huge favor to many parts of the
country that desperately need to see new
jobs and investment and good wages in
them
but that at the same time it would help
us to cut carbon emissions and reduce
our dependence on imports of gas from
companies that come from countries like
russia and qatar that's got to be the
right approach and i hope that finally
after a decade of inaction the
government is going to wake up and
realize that this is critical to our
national security and critical to our
future prosperity
all right let's uh if i may i uh let me
catch up with uh with history and move
on from your old job to your current job
which is sharon shadow uh leveling up
secretary you you praised the um
the government's uh
desire for leveling up uh and in places
like grimsby where you
and your leader were this week to look
at investment uh that's taking place in
offshore wind power um do you want to
see what do you want to see more of in
the leveling up white paper
well look we we welcome the small pots
of money that have been announced for 20
places today
that's a a small refund on the amount
that we've lost since the prime minister
took office and i think those 20 places
will be glad to have any penny back that
they can get because any penny counts
but i think there is a profound sense
that the government has really missed
the point with the very small
beer that they've given us this morning
they've got to get money back into
people's pockets right across this
country town centres are
not thriving high streets are falling
apart because not only have we seen good
wages good jobs depart from many parts
of the country over recent decades it's
been turbocharged in the last 10 years
and right now energy bills are going up
shopping prices are sky high and people
are about to face a tax hike michael
gove talks about king's cross style
regeneration but if you want king's
cross-style regeneration you've got to
put money back into people's pockets so
that they can spend you've got to get
those good jobs back in king's cross
cost three billion to redevelop the
government's stake alone was worse three
times what they're giving to the entire
rest of the country with this money
that's been recycled from the budget
these are places that within living
memory powered this country places like
grimsby places like wigan and we deserve
the right to make that contribution
again we are ambitious for this country
why isn't the government
oh yes but i'd like to
ask you lisa nandy what what would you
do i mean when you uh talked about
leveling up this weekend and previously
you've got
particular interest in the position of
towns
um
one of the things that you've said is
that you don't want people to have to
get out to get on that they don't have
to leave where they've grown up and live
in order to get good jobs to be socially
mobile and so on
how do you want to achieve that and
what's it going to cost
so we want young people to have choices
and chances and we've already made a
significant commitment from a future
labour government as to what that would
mean 28 billion pounds investment every
year for the life of the next parliament
in green energy that means the sort of
jobs and apprenticeships that i saw in
grimsby with kyostama last week the sort
of chances and choices for young people
that are too often denied to them unless
we take that seriously unless we get
that investment back into places the
transport infrastructure the digital
infrastructure so that we can leverage
in private sector investment it's
businesses in grimsby that have been
driving that improvement and getting
that investment into grimsby and those
opportunities back again unless we do
that unless we rebuild the foundations
of our local economies and allow people
the chance not just to have jobs but
good jobs again that make a contribution
we will have profoundly missed the point
that's what is so disappointing about
the government's announcement today
we've got to be far more ambitious than
that
yes you've okay let's you you've been
saying for a couple weeks now that the
whole party gate salga and so on has
been distracting the government um two
weeks ago you said the prime minister's
position was untenable um
but he's still there
the delay around the sugrey
report and the mets launching its own
investigation
probably mean that actually that's going
to be the situation
for some time possibly for months
has labor missed its shot
at the prime minister
look the prime minister could end this
circus today he could just be honest
about what has been going on you and i
know he's not going to he you and i know
he's not going to your job as an
opposition if you as a way you describe
it is to get rid of him have you missed
the opportunity did you fumble the ball
well in the end it's it's up to two
groups of people tory mps who could if
they wanted to trigger um for the prime
minister to go or back a vote of no
confidence in the house of commons but i
think it's unlikely both have no
confidence moved by the labour party or
or
it will move by the labour party if tory
mps will support it there's no point in
just perpetuating the circus people have
got real problems
or it's up to the public in the end the
prime minister if he stays will have to
face the public in a general election
but just consider for a moment what you
said trevor we just agreed and moved on
very quickly from the idea that the
prime minister could put an end to this
be honest and come clean but he's not
going to that is why this circus is
continuing that is why the country is
being held back that is why this
leveling up white paper frankly doesn't
appear to be worth the paper that it's
written on these promises that have been
made to us are not being kept because
the prime minister is saying yeah but
it's a criminal investigation to tell
him whether he was even at a party i
guess but it's not my third it's it's
not my job to make moral judgments about
the prime minister what i'm asking you
is if you think it's all so terrible
he's so ghastly he's making a mess of
the country
why haven't you been able to do anything
about it that's the job of opposition
and i'm just asking you whether you
think
uh when you had the opportunity
you missed it
well just i don't know what you're
asking me to do do you want me to go
down to london now and frog march him
out of downing street i mean in the end
we live in a democracy and if tory mps
won't find the backbone and the courage
to do the right thing then it will be up
to the british people what we'll do is
the official opposition is leave no
stone unturned we will not rest until
people who have been bereaved people
who've lost loved ones people who made
huge sacrifices have got answers from
the prime minister about what was going
on on his watch and we'll continue to do
our job in speaking up for people who
are watching these broken promises with
utter dismay people deserve better
chances and choices than the ones that
are currently on offer to them they deal
they deserve a government that will deal
with the cost of living crisis and will
actually start to rebuild our great
towns and cities right across this
country and until they have one we
simply will not rest that is our job and
we will do it